>> Fred Bowen: All right.
Good afternoon.
My name is Fred Bowen
and I am the author
of 23 kids' sports books
for kids ages seven to 12.
And I also write a
weekly kids' sports column
for the Kids' Post page
of the Washington Post,
which is a charter sponsor of
the National Book Festival.
Before I introduce
our next speaker,
first we should have a word
of thanks for the cochairman
of the festival,
David Rubenstein,
and the other generous sponsors
who made this event possible.
If you'd like to add
your financial support
to the National Book Festival,
a way to do it is in the program
at the back, and it would
certainly be a great way
to support things.
By the way, after our next
author's presentation,
there will be questions
and answers,
and if you would please step
up to mics that you see there.
So, it is now my great pleasure
to introduce Suzanne Slade.
Suzanne Slade is an
award-winning author
of more than a hundred books.
I thought I was doing great with
23; she has more than a hundred.
Most of the books are about
science, and that's probably
because Suzanne was
a mechanical engineer
who actually worked on rockets.
Her latest book is
called Countdown:
2979 Days to the Moon,
and it is the story
of the US Space Program from the
President Kennedy announcement
that we were going
to go to the Moon
until we stepped onto the Moon.
It is a fabulous book.
I have seen it.
She will be signing the book
at 4:30 after this at booth 20.
It has already gotten starred
reviews from Publishers Weekly,
from Booklist, but most
of Suzanne's books
get starred reviews.
She is a wonderful author.
And so, without further
ado, let's have a big round
of applause for Suzanne Slade.
[ Applause ]
>> Suzanne Slade:
Thank you, Fred.
>> Fred Bowen: Knock 'em dead.
>> Suzanne Slade: Thank you.
Well, thank you very much.
I'm so excited to be at
the National Book Festival
to celebrate reading and books.
And, of course, my book
Countdown, which is illustrated
by New York Times bestselling
illustrator Thomas Gonzalez.
Now, this book covers
2979 incredible days
from when Kennedy announced we
should land a man on the Moon
by the end of this decade, which
you'll hear in his own words.
>> I believe [inaudible].
>> Suzanne Slade:
He's saying that.
He's saying, "We'll land
a man on this Moon --
>> Of landing a man on the Moon
and returning him
safely to the Earth.
>> Suzanne Slade: Excellent.
Until Neil Armstrong's
first step on the Moon.
>> I believe --
>> Suzanne Slade: Oh.
There we go.
So, what I wanted
to do with this book
with Apollo was I wanted to
share not only the successes
of those early missions but
also a lot of the struggles
and the surprises that happened
in those early Apollo missions
that not many people are
aware of, because they led
to the most historic - one
of the most historic events
in history, the first
Moon-landing.
>> Two, one, zero.
Liftoff. We have a liftoff.
[ Inaudible ]
[ Music ]
>> It seemed that the whole
world had stopped as man had set
out on the adventure to
escape from his own planet
and to set foot on
a distant one.
>> Suzanne Slade: So,
just a little background.
As Fred said, I'm a
mechanical engineer.
And I worked at McDonnell
Douglas Space Systems
in California.
And some of the spacecraft
I worked on were the Titan
and Delta rockets and the
Delta-Star spacecraft.
So, I do have a big personal
interest in space travel.
So, I thought it
would be fun today
to do something a
little interactive,
that I could give
you an Apollo quiz,
which will help you
test your knowledge
of these early Apollo missions
that led to the big landing.
And also you can
learn something new.
So, are you ready for the quiz?
All right.
Question one.
The very first Apollo mission,
Apollo 1, was: a huge success,
a national disaster,
or delayed for years?
What do you think?
I've got a gentleman here,
what do you think, sir?
He thinks it was a huge success!
But unfortunately, it was
in fact a national disaster
that almost ended the
entire Apollo Program.
That very first mission, just
a few weeks before they were
to launch in January of
'67, there was a fire
on the launchpad while they
were doing routine testing.
They weren't even
trying to launch.
And that fire killed all three
of the Apollo 1 astronauts.
And at that time, after that
disaster, the nation started
to think, "Do we really want
to try to go to the Moon?"
And, no one was sure if the
Apollo mission would continue.
But they decided it would.
So, NASA grounded
Apollo 2 and 3,
because those spacecraft
were the same
as the one that burned up.
So, they had to check
out what was wrong.
They redesigned the
command module.
And then, the world then
nervously watched while Apollo
4 launched.
So, another question.
What do you think, did
it launch with no crew,
three astronauts,
or a chimpanzee?
And while you think
about your answer,
you can watch the launch.
>> Ignition sequence starts.
Five, four -- we have ignition.
All engines are running.
We have liftoff.
We liftoff at 7:00 a.m.
Eastern Standard Time.
>> Suzanne Slade: All right.
I have a gentleman
right here that would
like to give me the answer.
What do you think?
He thinks C, a chimpanzee.
That's a very good guess.
But --
Okay, now how do I go back?
No crew. It was actually
new crew.
So what they did,
just to be safe,
on the next three missions --
>> Ignition sequence --
>> Suzanne Slade: Four, five
and six, they all went unmanned.
They could test the spacecraft,
they could test their
flight plans.
They wanted to make sure
there was not another accident
like they had on
that first mission.
So, question three.
Then, on Apollo 7 was
the first manned mission.
It orbited Earth 163
times successfully.
But, this crew staged a
mutiny when they refused to:
eat dried spinach, where helmets
to land, or go to bed at 11:00?
What do we think?
They were -- we have a guess.
Yes, dear?
She thinks B, wear helmets.
We've got a very
smart young girl here.
In fact, they did refuse
to wear the helmets,
and they were not worried
about having helmet hair
when they landed and
the press was there.
That was not the concern.
They all had developed bad
colds while they were in flight.
And when you're up in space
where there's very
little gravity,
your sinuses can't drain, and
it was a matter of safety.
They were worried if
their helmets were on,
and they couldn't
clear their noses
and their sinuses,
they might choke.
But Mission Control was not
happy about this at all.
There were some harsh
words exchanged,
which I read in the transcript.
And then none of those
astronauts ever flew another
Apollo mission because
of their mutiny.
Okay, question four.
Apollo 8 was the first
crew to orbit the Moon.
And during one telecast,
Jim Lovell --
you probably remember
him maybe from Apollo 13,
which is later -- Jim Lovell
demonstrated how astronauts:
exercise, make chocolate
pudding, or navigate in space?
Yes, sir? He thinks how they
exercise, which they do exercise
in space, but in fact, Jim made
up a bag of chocolate pudding.
And he telecasts this.
This was halfway on
their way to the Moon.
You'll be able to
see this footage.
It's a little old, so it's
grainy, but you'll see him
with his chocolate
pudding float by.
>> Jim is making dessert.
He's making up a bag
of chocolate pudding.
[Inaudible] floating by.
>> Suzanne Slade:
Another cool thing
about this mission was
this crew was the first
to see an earthrise,
which is the Earth rising
above the surface of the Moon.
And they got that
beautiful picture
to share with us earthlings.
So, question five.
Now we're up to Apollo 4.
And they had a Lunar Module
which they named Spider,
which if you look at
it, it kind of does,
a little bit like a spider.
But it flew like a dream.
But the crew did
have problems with,
do you think low
batteries, motion sickness,
or losing things in their ship?
Yes, dear?
She thinks they had
problems with batteries.
In fact, it was the
other two items.
They had trouble
with motion sickness
and losing things in their ship.
One of the astronauts, Rusty
Schweickart, became very ill
and they weren't even sure
if he was going to be able
to do his spacewalk, but
he was able to do it.
And also, the crew kept losing
toothbrushes, food bags.
So, they learned that --
they learned two things:
they need to Velcro their items
in place so they don't float
around the cabin and get
lost, and they learned
that vomit droplets
are hard to catch.
Because, once things are free
and, you know, it was a smelly,
messy ordeal from what I read.
Okay, question six.
We're up to Apollo 10.
This is the mission
before America's going
to attempt to land.
So they had the crucial job.
They had to scout
the landing location
where Apollo 11 would
attempt to land.
So when they were done
with their work, to relax,
they liked to listen
to this song.
Do you think it was
Fly Me to the Moon,
Space Cowboy, or Moondance?
Yes, dear?
She thinks Fly Me to the
Moon, and she is right.
Oh, and look at the
ancient technology.
Anybody remember the
cassette player for --
it was some ancient
technology they had onboard.
Yes, it was Fly Me to the
Moon, and the ironic thing
about that was that
this mission,
these people flew
closer to the Moon
than any human had ever been.
They were in fact nine miles
from the surface of the Moon.
Okay. Finally, Apollo 11,
Neil Armstrong has landed.
So, how many people do you think
watched Neil Armstrong take
that first historic step
on the Moon on live TV?
Yes, sir?
>> A lot.
>> Suzanne Slade: He said a
lot, our choices are 2 million,
100 million, or 600 million?
>> A hundred million.
>> He's guessing 100, that's
very good, but in fact -- oh.
We have to see it.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Thirty seconds.
>> Oh, jeez.
>> Tranquility Base here.
The Eagle has landed.
[Inaudible]
>> Man on the Moon.
>> Whew.
>> Boy.
>> [Inaudible] going to
be busy for a minute.
>> There he is.
There's a foot coming
down the step.
>> I'm at the foot
of the ladder.
>> Armstrong is on the
Moon, Neil Armstrong,
38-year-old American, standing
on the surface of the Moon,
on this July 20th, 1969.
>> That's one small step for
man, one giant leap for mankind.
>> Suzanne Slade:
Quite an historic day.
And guess what?
People around the world stopped
whatever they were doing to see
that first man on the Moon.
We have people, thousands
of people
in New York's Central
Park gathered
to watch it on a large screen.
Up at the top corner you
see a business in Italy
where people just stopped
work and gathered around a TV.
An airport in Sydney, it didn't
matter where they were going.
They wanted to stop and see that
a man was actually on the Moon.
And of course, homes around
the world, people had parties.
They had Moon-landing parties,
and everyone hoped it would end
up being a good party
and they would land
and they would survive when
they stepped out on the Moon.
Okay, this is our last question.
So, once the Apollo 11
astronauts returned home,
they were quarantined to protect
the world from Moon germs.
Because doctors didn't know
if there were viruses or germs
on the Moon that could
bring home an infection
that would wipe out
our entire planet.
So, here you see the
crew is being greeted
by President Nixon
from behind glass.
So, how long do you think they
quarantined the astronauts?
>> Twenty-four hours!
>> Suzanne Slade: Twenty-four
hours, seven days or 21 days?
Yes? She said seven days?
That's a great guess, but
they were a little nervous.
They wanted to be
sure, so in fact,
they quarantined
them for 21 days.
And then after that,
they celebrated.
Everyone celebrated.
>> What was it we were
really celebrating?
Three men who had done what
no man before had done?
A technological feat was
believed beyond the realm
of possibility?
A fulfillment of
an age-old dream?
Were we celebrating simply
because it had been a long time
since we had anything
to celebrate?
Or was this something that
touched an irrational,
unthinking instinct in us all?
>> Suzanne Slade: So, the
celebration included parades
in major cities like
New York and Chicago.
There you also see
the astronauts
and their wives being
invited to state dinners.
The entire world joined together
and could celebrate together
because of this incredible feat
that most people quite frankly
didn't think was possible.
So, just a little background.
I began Countdown
in the fall of 2009.
This was shortly after
the 40th anniversary
of the first Moon landing.
And I thought, "I would like to
create a special book in time
for the 50th anniversary,"
which will be this
coming July of 2019.
So, ironically as I look back,
it took about 2979 days for me
to create this book, which
is a little over eight years.
Now, as a writer, what happens
is there are often several
stages that you go through.
And the first stage,
when I first get a book
idea, I am very excited.
And I think, "This is
going to be awesome!
I can't wait to dig
into research.
This is going to be fun!"
But, as the days, weeks, months
and years go on, as a writer --
especially of non-fiction --
you hit a lot of times
that you get frustrated.
Sometimes you hit roadblocks.
I get tired, the fact-checking.
So, there are many
stages that I went
through until the
book was finished.
But I'm very excited.
Today is the day the book
releases, coincidently enough.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
And I'm very excited about
it because I want to share,
there's so much interesting
history here
that I feel young readers and
older readers don't realize.
I really think you'll
be fascinated to read
about this time in history.
As I mentioned, research
was really one
of the most fascinating steps.
And I got to do some
exciting things.
Something I never thought
I would be able to do --
for instance, I interviewed
Alan Bean.
He was the fourth
man on the Moon.
He was on the Apollo 12
mission, the mission right
after the first landing.
And he was kind enough
to allow me
to do a couple interviews
with him.
I also, of course, looked
through the NASA transcripts,
which any of you can look.
They're online.
You can read every word
that the astronauts
and Mission Control shared.
I looked at the Apollo
photo archives.
I emailed with Walt Cunningham,
Apollo 12, which was interesting
because his emails -- he's in
his 80s, so his emails come back
in a very big font, and short.
"Yes." "No."
But it was all the
information I needed.
So, that -- it was just really
fun to research this book.
Meanwhile, once the publisher,
Peachtree Publishers picked
up the book, my fabulous
illustrator Tom Gonzalez was
doing research of his
own, was making sketches.
He will make changes
as we go along.
And then painting his final art,
which is absolutely gorgeous.
His work is just
stunning in this book.
So, as I mentioned, Countdown
releases today, so I can't think
of a better place to celebrate
than with fellow booklovers
like you here at the
National Book Festival.
It is 144 pages long.
It's for ages ten and up.
It's technically a middle grade.
It's in free verse,
so it makes it easy
for reluctant readers as well.
There's 54 illustrations,
and I'm just very excited
to share it with readers.
So, I just thought that I'd see
if you have any questions
you'd like to ask me.
I would love to answer
any questions.
It could be about research,
or the Apollo missions,
or writing -- whatever
you're interested in.
>> I have one question.
Who was filming -- because
if it was the first step,
I just wonder who was
filming into the rocket?
>> Suzanne Slade:
You are a very --
like who was filming him
taking the first step
on the Moon, right?
Sharp, very good question.
So, NASA had thought
ahead, right?
And they knew everyone
would want to see this,
so they had put a special camera
on the outside of
the Lunar Module.
And the Lunar Module
is the spacecraft
that lands on the Moon.
So, once they landed, they
could pop the camera out.
As you saw, the footage,
it was kind of grainy.
It wasn't high quality.
But that's how they were able
to have that camera film him
as Armstrong went out
and took his first step.
Great question.
>> Would you ever like
to go to the Moon?
>> Suzanne Slade: Someone
help me with that question?
>> I think she asked if
you want to go to the Moon.
>> Suzanne Slade: If I
want to go to the Moon.
You know? I really liked looking
at all the pictures of the Moon,
but I don't think I'm quite
brave enough to want to go.
Because every time
an astronaut went
and actually 12 people landed
on the Moon, but you never know
if you were going to make it.
So maybe I'm not that brave.
But I'd like to read about it.
Thank you.
>> I changed my mind.
>> Are you planning on
writing any more books?
>> Suzanne Slade: Am I
planning on writing any more --
yes, I actually have seven other
books that are in the works
with other publishers.
So, if you're interested
in the Moon landing,
this Countdown book, in
March I have a book coming
out called the Daring Dozen,
because as I mentioned,
12 people have been on the Moon.
That book is for a little
younger readers, and it talks
about what they did
on their missions
and what they found on the Moon.
And I've got another book coming
up in March called A
Computer Called Catherine.
And it's about Catherine
Johnson who was a human computer
who helped plot the
trajectories for all
of these -- for many missions.
>> I'm going to still
think about it.
>> Suzanne Slade: Thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> How many Apollo
missions have there been?
>> Suzanne Slade: There have
been 17 Apollo missions.
But as I mentioned, Apollo 2
and 3 were scrubbed, and then 4,
5 and 6 were unmanned.
But 17 is our total.
>> What did it feel
like reading the book?
I mean, making the book?
>> Suzanne Slade: What do I
feel like making the book?
You know what?
I tell you, at the
beginning I feel, "Yoo-hoo,
I'm going to make a book!"
And then I get researching
and working and I'm going,
"Oh wow, this is really hard.
This is harder than I thought.
I don't know if I can do it."
You ever feel like
that sometimes?
But then I keep working and
I keep working, and I --
then I get feelings
of being tired
and excited about research.
So, lots of feelings
go into making a book.
Thank you.
>> When you were younger, was
science your favorite subject?
>> Suzanne Slade: Yes.
In fact, science and math
were my favorite subjects.
And can I tell you a secret
you won't tell my publisher?
Okay, writing was my least
favorite subject in school.
It was! But I was a huge reader.
I joined my summer reading club
at my library every summer,
and I read lots and
lots of books.
And reading helps you
become a better writer.
So, I think it was key
that I kept reading.
>> How did you guys
know how much food
that you needed on the trip?
>> Suzanne Slade: You
mean the trip to the Moon?
Great question.
Well, they had nutritionists,
and those are people who study
about food, who worked
to package all the meals
for the astronauts.
And they were all packaged which
-- each astronaut had a color,
I believe, of the bags
that would have their food.
And they knew, "At this meal,
this is exactly what
I'm eating."
So they planned out the calories
and how much nutrition
they would need.
And they would add water to
the food before they ate it.
Great question.
>> If you could go to the Moon,
what would you bring with you?
>> Suzanne Slade: Gosh, I
don't know but you know what?
You remind me of
something that Alan Bean --
remember I said I interviewed
the fourth man on the Moon?
And he said he had one
regret about his mission,
and that was he wished he had
taken a football to the Moon,
because he wanted to throw the
longest pass in the universe.
Because on the Moon there's
one-sixth of the gravity
that we have on Earth,
and there's no air.
So, if you could
throw a football,
it would have gone for forever.
So, thank you.
>> How long did it take
to land on the Moon?
>> Suzanne Slade: How
long did it take to land?
That's a great question
because actually they --
on the Lunar Module, the
thing that was going to land,
they only put just
enough fuel to land.
So, once they took off to
land, they had to land quickly.
And so it got very tense
as Apollo 11 was landing;
they were almost out of fuel.
So, it didn't take
long at all for them
to find their spot and land.
Great question.
>> How long have you
been writing books?
>> Suzanne Slade: I've
been writing books
for about 22 years.
But guess what?
It took eight years to get
my first book published.
For eight years, when I'd mail
my story to the publishers,
the people who make the
books, all I heard back
from them was, "No, thank you.
We don't want to
publish your book."
And that's called
a rejection letter.
So, I had to be persistent,
and I had a lot
to learn about writing.
Because I was an engineer,
so I had to learn a lot.
But I'm glad that
I stuck so when --
last thing I want to say before
I leave, for you kids who,
when you try something new
and when you first do it,
maybe you're not
really good at it.
Maybe soccer, or
playing a new instrument.
But if you love it, keep at it.
Because the more you practice,
the better you'll get.
Which is exactly what
happened with me and writing.
So, well, thank you.
I've been told we're out of
time but thank you for being
such a wonderful audience.
And if you want to sign my book
or meet with me, I'll be 4:30
to 5:30 in the signing area.
Thank you.